so I'm late come guys how are you doing
you know what song maker mean yes
peace peace be with you there we go
peace be with you I'm here in Orlando
and I met Christopher Christopher you
know there's a lot of security guards in
front of us now because of the and I'll
let you explain that why is there more
security right like for instance in
front of the mosque we know there's a
growing threat of Islamophobia right
right so we got our brothers here who
are out watching making sure because
there's been mas vandalized bond
firebomb you've heard of these so many
situations can you well pretty much
after the radical 9/11 happened they are
now a lot more scared and fearful of
people who think they are a part of that
you know bad culture they think that all
Muslims are all the same they're all
evil this than the third and I want to
say that that is not true
these people are very nice the very kind
sincere and this is a place of worship
the place that I guard is us school and
also a mosque I guard both and I want
you guys to know that everything's fine
here everything's nice and they need
security because people are trying to
harm them there are people out there
that are trying to take these people out
sadly and I want you to know that that's
not gonna happen with us on here isn't
that beautiful thank you so much have
you visited a mosque have you so now
most people that come and they're around
Muslims they see exactly what is the
most hospitable kind nice generous
people have you had a chance to actually
I know it's kind of too soon to tell but
have also people because you know once
people really get to know Islam they
really appreciate it and it's every
Muslims duty to share what we know has
anybody help to you know educate you on
what Islam is all about now that is an
important question I had
the principal his name is a brother
Jameer he just presently brought me a
little brushed brushed breeze on to me
about the Nation of Islam and how long
basically you know they could help me
and how long you know the truth you know
it's basically about knowing how love
knowing God knowing the Prophet Muhammad
those two you know can be in my life in
the leaf if I choose to yeah so this is
just one thing Nation of Islam is
something totally different if I just
confused this is just Islam okay yeah
nation there is no this is something
this is what we this is something with
Farrakhan and what now we say they
missed this law okay this is Islam there
we go because Malcolm X Muhammad Ali
they were part of this movement but then
they came to the real Islam oh they came
to you know when they when Malcolm X
when he went to Hajj as the fifth pillar
of Islam he was standing next to the
white and the black and the yellow and
people of all different nationalities
and colors all coming together to
worship one guy okay so we usually tell
people you know the main message of
Islam is to worship the Creator not to
creation that's right that's the main
message and God out of his love over
time he sent messengers and every
messenger including Jesus Moses the last
the final measure problem hummock be
supposed to be upon him they all came at
the same message you know that message
was don't work go ahead I'll answer if
you can't go ahead eat one and only one
God worshiping the creator and not the
creation and then the second part is the
belief in the messengers that the God
Almighty sent messengers out of his love
G did you know that it's an article of
faith for Muslims to believe in love
Jesus did you know that yes you learned
that already I wash a lot to believe
that he was a mighty messenger he came
with the same message not a different
message than Moses than Abraham and the
last to final mission problem Ahom a
piece of us would be upon him which was
that call to submit your will to the
creator of the heavens an Arab not to
worship Jesus not to worship a man a
woman
money fame your desires but to only
worship God one God right and they
brought awareness to the hereafter the
day of judgment that they were all going
to be accountable for we did in his life
that there is accountability that after
we leave this life God's going to ask us
what we did in this life we just go
ahead and play this life is a test and
then that after you pass the test
there's a paradise you worship the One
God you do what he wants you to do you
implement the submission to his will and
you know what one word in Arabic which
means submission to the will of God you
know what that is you're learning that's
where you hear I'm sharing is Islam it's
a flaw me yes submission to the will of
God that's what Islam means and the
Muslim is one who does Islam a Muslim is
one who submits to the will of God
that's it you see that and anybody did
you know that anyone could be a Muslim
anyone hey you are you come from or what
what kind of background um uh you can
say property Christian you can say
beautiful that's it and then as Muslims
we share you know and then and if let's
say to today right now you said you know
what I like that I want to be a Muslim
my person was just declared that there's
nothing worthy of worship except the
Creator and Muhammad is the final
messenger sent to mankind that's it and
that would automatically include Jesus
Moses Abraham and all the preceding
messages that came before him with the
same message was the message submission
to who Islam to the submission to the
will of God will of God that's it and
then they established they come and
establish the prayer in the mosque or at
home five times a day right and then
they go ahead and pay the charity right
two or five percent of your your your
acts as well after you've lost bet paid
everybody off you know your workers and
then fast during the month of Ramadan
and then the Hajj what I talked about
Malcolm X did right those are the five
pillars
so that's that's really it you know
that's Islam if you follow me believe
from one guy believed in his angels the
books that were revealed to Jesus to
Moses - to problem Hamid the Koran and
you know to believe in the day of
judgement all right paradise Hellfire I
mean this is you know this is these are
the simple concept that I tell you
anything that's strange you know
something that just doesn't make sense
it's absurd what what is your honest
opinion from what I shared with you what
is your honest opinion of the things
that that I've said this is anything
there that you can agree with um I do
agree that uh I do believe in Jesus
being the Messenger of God I do believe
that that he came you know fallen from
heaven in the form that he knows his
mission his mission was to make sure
that people would worship God I do
believe in that as well
and I do think that um the nation
you know the whole congregation of Islam
it's just Islam no more community of yet
community of Muslims I feel like they
had their very underrated you know I
feel like people don't give them the
digit diligence that they deserve you
know I believe that they think it's more
folklore about you guys than anything I
believe that's that's not the case I
believe you guys are very serious about
you know your love and commitment to
Allah
you know God and now law just means God
you know in in other terms and I feel
like the way you guys share that the way
you guys share your love for one another
for Brotherhood it's it's unbreakable
it's a bond that even I can't really
comprehend because I never had you know
a close bond like that before
I'm really amazed you know a lot look I
didn't even have to get into the word a
lot you know Christians and Jews who are
Arabic speaking he they use the word a
lot many people don't know that because
many people they think this is some like
you know because of the false propaganda
that this is some foreign God but right
this is in Aramaic the language Jesus
spoke he didn't speak Greek in his big
English
he didn't say God he said Aloha in
Arabic Allah look at the the closeness
that's so amazing
tell me you know you mentioned something
really profound and I speak to a lot of
Christians are our brothers and sisters
in humanity and they also they both many
of them you know when they think outside
the box and they hear this they say when
I asked them do you believe Jesus was
God or sent by God they say I believe I
got like a Messenger of God that really
connects with people you just said it so
you're pretty much if I asked you do you
believe that nothing should be
worshipped except the crater that
happens in Earth who created creation
would you agree to that I would yes I
would I would agree
oh and you believe that Jesus is a
Messenger of God yes I do believe he was
messenger you know what the only thing
left is for one to be a Muslim is to
believe that Muhammad is the last and
final messenger and then that's it there
are Muslim oh do you know anything about
Prophet Muhammad not not yet not yet
have to do some more research on
property well we're here for you because
that's it once someone believes that
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the crater the heavens and earth and
Arabic we say Allah and that Jesus is a
messenger problem Hamid is the last and
final messenger that's it
they declare that you know that belief
comes out of their their heart to their
lips and they're Muslim they're ones who
have submitted to the truth now once
they start implementing Islam now
they're gonna grow in this belief
they're gonna grow in the love for it
but now when you recognize the truth you
know that's why we usually give the
invitation of people hey it's not our
job to call hurt someone twist my arm
and say oh boy
it's up to them you know it's like
inviting someone over for coffee dinner
correct they can accept are they fair
eject
so has an open juice yeah so people
forget what's the center day great
greater Center of Greater Muslim center
of our land oh it's great school I want
to know that leave on Tuesdays and
Thursdays I think they have a open house
and it's also to talk about the faith of
Islam Islam there we go
and yeah if you guys want to check it
out that's also over there as well I
might check it out as well - there you
go there you go
thank you let me share some of this with
you yes and you know it's about just
being open-minded you know for the mind
to work it needs to be like a great
thinker said like a parachute your mind
is open now the heart is open I usually
leave people with something real simple
you know it's so simple that it's like
an aha moment it's like why not just
think of that
for people that ascertain the truth you
know upon using the faculties of the
crater's giving us of our logic
reasoning as to what ask the Creator the
one up above you know this creation who
created creation say guide me you ask
the Creator guide me why am I here
everything has a purpose in this life
what about the human being right
that badge look right there has a
purpose you know your shoes have a
purpose the gun the pistol has a purpose
but what about the one who's carrying
the badge the pistol the keys does he
not have a purpose so its up on ups to
us to ask the Creator who created us
what's my purpose is the truth here
they're everywhere what is it and then
keep our hearts open our minds open and
see where we go from there be courageous
also enough when the truth comes to
accepting I left you with the business
car for the details yes continue
continue
tuning in watch it thank you so much yes
definitely it was a pleasure guys thank
you thank you god bless you thank you so
much
like a bunch of different races
ethnicities
coming together all for their worship
we started at the time
they
why're what background you come from
one cuddle
watch the game show lost detail make
sure you watch the dude show watch the
Dean show watch the Dean show watch the
Dean so watch the future
watch the do so